for
please rise for the chairman of Sate
District
Council
e
so good evening members and me and
officers of the council and members of
the press and public I welcome you to
the meeting of the
council if the fire alarm is activated
please vocate the office via the stairs
either through the security door to my
right or opposite the left in the flo
foer please do not use the lift please
assemble in hogley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber right I would advise you that
filming takes place anyone in attendance
of the public areas may have their image
captured I urge anybody filming process
to avoid filming the members of the
public particularly if there are
children
present does anybody intend to film the
meeting no
right thank
you if any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
inclusion of the press and public from
the
meeting would everybody present ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst this meeting
is in
progress item agenda number one
apologies for absence I have received
apologies from councelor Dennis PA Mo
and Owen Hughes are there any other
apologies for
absence silence
item agend agenda item two minutes of
the previous meeting I move that the
minutes of the meeting of the council
held on the 12th of October 2023 be
approved and signed as a correct
record do I have a second
second do members agree agre right thank
you item agenda number three of
announcements I have not been informed
of any
announcements agenda item four de
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of
Interest agenda item five petitions
result of one petition being reported to
the council in accordance with the
council petition Pro
protocol agenda item 5 a yellow lime
petition the council's response to the
petition is outl lien report before
members do members have any
comments all right thank you agenda item
six questions from the press and public
there have been nine questions received
from the press and public in accordance
with Council
procedure rule number 13
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of questions from the
press and the public shall not re shall
not exceed 30 minutes this is a clearly
stated in the council's
Constitution questions that are not put
to the at the meeting due to the time
limit of 30 minutes will be answered in
writing please note only the
questionnaire and the respondent are
permitted to speak on the
question
could the questionnaire please only
state the name of the cabinet member to
whom the question is put to be put and
read out exactly the exact wording of
the
question that they have submitted to the
council right so agenda item 6A question
number
one a member of the public regarding
Southern water I'm pleased to welcome
Miss Brown to the meeting will you make
your way to the
microphone thank you chair um my
question is addressed to the lead of the
council councilor Kett um at the
overview and scrutiny meeting with
Southern water on the 14th of March 2023
Mr Tim manah director of Southern water
operations said that although there are
not statutary consules on housing
developments if they're invited by local
councils they can attend meetings about
applications for large developments in
advisory
capacity is TTC intending to invite sou
Mor to meetings of developers and
planning meetings where large
developments are discussed and outline
planning author is to be decided with
developments like the 2,000 houses at
West Kate and Garland will do TDC inore
Southern water are invited to all the
individual planning meetings for example
for 150 houses as well as for outline
planning for 2,000 houses and what steps
will TDC take to mitigate the fact that
southern water is unable to provide
effective waste water disposal thank you
thank you m brown I call upon the leader
to
respond thank you chair um and thank you
for your question m brown um the council
notifies Southern water of all planning
applications which require a new
connection to the waste water Network
all representations received from
Southern water are available for viewing
on the council's website and are taken
into account when the council makes a
decision on these applications in
addition the council consults with
Southern water and other utilities
providers during the preparation of the
thanet local plan to ensure that water
supply and drainage issues are fully
considered as part of this
process Southern water is required to
provide a connection to Developers for
fou and surface water drainage under the
water industry act it should be noted
that in 2024 the right to connect to the
seage network as part of new development
is to be removed for surface water
runoff which is the primary component
that results in flooding and sewage
release in addition new Housing
Development is required to implement
sustainable Urban drainage solutions
that ensure rainwater runoff is able to
soak away rather than enter the sewage
system the council will continue to
engage with Southern water to ensure
that adequate drainage systems are in
place to support new housing development
in the district district and we will
invite them to meet with officers where
there are particular issues with
drainage on individual developments and
I'd like to just clarify because that
doesn't quite answer your question
although I'm the cabinet member for
planning I'm not the chair of the
planning committee and I'm not
responsible for who's invited to the
planning committee meetings so I can't
reli you an answer to that but we will
give it
consideration thank
you thank you agenda item 6B question
number two from a member of the public
regarding sunning Dow Housing
Development I'm pleased to welcome Mr
woodwood to the meeting could you please
make your way to the
microphone so if he's not
here I can't
hear
um he didn't receive a reply to tell him
his question had been accepted so that's
why he's not
here so he will get an answer in
writing right agenda item 6C question
number three from the member of the
public regarding warpo
boat I have that question this is a
protest
why we going tojin the
meeting
have been killed with I would kindly ask
you all to stop disrupting the
proceedings of the meeting if you do not
stop disrupting the proceedings I will
be forced to clear the public
Gallery due to your contined disorder
conduct I am ordering the clearance to
the public G you are required to leave
the chamber just like other L councils
have done around the country stand up
people for civilians stand up for women
stand up for children and you know what
actually stand up for men cuz we don't
deserve to be slaughtered either you
all
security could you please ask the member
of the public to leave the
chamber
for
members just to can confirm we've
adjourned the meeting while this is
going on so the time will be held and
security are coming there's not not much
more we can do at this stage in room you
want to take the opportunity to go to
the toilet they'll take
itde don't be complicit in a genocide
how many children
how many children have to die before you
do something people in maret want you to
do something you are our represent so
the police are on the way up I just
wanted to let you know we
need
right where were we then so we are
agenda item 6 C question number three
from member of the public regarding wo
Bay Mr Lee is unable to attend the
meeting the full Council we will
response in
writing item agenda item 6D question
number four for the member of the public
regarding wool Bay I'm pleased to
M I'm pleased to welcome Miss Wate to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the microphone she not here
either no no okay she's not attending so
sure
SEC get a question right answer right
agenda item 6 e question number five for
a member of the public regarding W Bay
Miss mcky is unable to attend the
meeting of the full Council and we will
be responding
writing agenda item
6f question number six from the member
of the public regarding wo Bay I am
pleased to welcome Miss P to the meeting
could you please make your way to the
microphone
[Applause]
somebody
it thank you um my question is addressed
to councelor album and may I just say as
a Preface on behalf of all the swimming
colleagues we'd like to acknowledge the
progress so far that has been undertaken
at wole tidle pool and particularly that
of the technical services team and
endon's work because um we understand
the Paul will be back in Saturday sorry
yes I will it was only 10 seconds as a
result of the storm damage around the
24th of November at warpole tidal pool
it is now unusable due to Stam damage
sles will Council confirm that urgent
attention is being given to establishing
the full extent of the damage that may
have occurred and that all necessary
repairs are undertaken without delay
attendance by contractors was noted on
29th of November what was the outcome of
that and what is the timetable for
carrying out all repairs
needed I am part of a large local group
of Swimmers at the pool which is a
nationally known unique and vitally
important asset both to the local and
visitor community and must not be
allowed to deteriorate
further as a grade two listed structure
there is a clear responsibility to fully
maintain it will Council please say what
plans are in place to ensure the
continued maintenance of it and the
surrounding physical infrastructure
thank you thank you m b call upon
councilor alurn to
respond uh thank you chair and and thank
you Mr Palmer um please you turned up
thank you for your question um the
council understands that warpole tidal
Bay is popular and well-used
facility by the community the council's
technical services team undertake a
survey twice a year as part of the
biannual Coastal inspections the team
undertakes repairs to the facility as
and when required using Coastal
maintenance
budget the team also responds to storm
damage straight away to ensure that any
repair required is done so quickly as
possible and the pool is
reopened the failed gate in one of the
three pen stock valves which served the
W Poole Bay tidle pool was replaced on
Monday the 4th of
December that's this
year um further repair work to another
of the three pen stock valves is
required before the pool is
refilled it is
anticipated and I'm pretty sure about
this uh that the poll will
reopen on the 15th of
December other maintenance activities in
the pool such as pointing and concrete
repair Works will be undertaken in the
meantime whilst the pool is out of
service thank
you thank
you go on to item agenda item 6G
question number seven from the member of
the public regarding waro Bay I am
pleased to welcome Mr Newton to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the
microphone good
evening
um Mr Auburn my uh question is for you
um however you've probably answered most
of um the queries that I'd actually made
um in answering Mr farmer so in view of
the fact that we've got several
questions to get through I'm quite happy
to
pass over this question and we carry on
thanks very much thank
you thank you Mr
P I just respond yes most certainly yeah
I'd just like to thank Mr Palmer for
that and it's I was just going to repeat
exactly the same thing so uh it just
gets gets us to get on with the business
thank you ever so much for that Mr
farmer thank
you
item agenda 68 number eight from the
member of the public regarded W Bay Mr
Walters is unable to attend and this
meeting of for Council will be responded
in
writing question agenda item
6061 question number nine from the
member of the public Regard in warpool
Bay I pleaseed to welcome Miss Leman to
the meeting could you please make your
way to
the and again you'll get an answer for
the question in
writing agender item seven questions to
the member of the council 13 questions
have been received from the members of
the council please note the time allowed
for consideration of the question from
the members shall not exceed 30 minutes
this is clearly stated in the council
Constitution I ask members to be as
suent as possible questions that are not
put to the meeting due to the time limit
of 30 minutes will be answered in
writing agenda item 7A question number
one from a member regarding the
electorial
registration I call upon councelor W
scobby thank you chair I'll try and be
succulent and I apologize that this does
not involve anything to do with Walpole
Bay um would the cabinet member please
explain the annual process that the
council goes through for electoral
registration and what is being done to
improve registration rates particularly
amongst hard-to-reach areas and groups
with higher levels of
deprivation I called upon councilor
yotes to
respond thank you chair and thank you
councelor scobby um an annual canvas of
properties is conducted from August to
the end of November each year in
preparation for republishing the
Electoral register on the 1st of
December prior to this the council's
data is sent to the DWP to verify that
the same information is held by both
once the DWP have run their checks the
data is loaded back onto the council's
electral management system and split
into canvas routes uh there are three
routes or go through them each Route One
this route applies where households
details held by the DWP and the council
have matched these properties are sent
an email confirming what information is
held by the council advising them that
they only need to apply to the letter if
there's been a change route two this uh
this route applies those properties
where there has been a conflict of
information held by the council and the
DWP they are sent a canvas form as
asking that they either go online to
update the household details or complete
the form and return it to the council
reminder forms are sent a month later to
all non-responding households and the
final stage is a telephone campus to the
outstanding properties uh route three
this route applies to Care Homes nursing
homes and houses in multipl occupation
they're sent a household form to
complete this is followed up with a
telephone canvas in addition to the
above households can update any details
throughout the year any time of the day
either by registering online or by
contacting the council's Electoral team
to to request a form to be sent to them
the team's contact details are on the
council's website together with details
of how to apply for a postal or proxy
vote um nationally we now have access as
the first as of October this year um for
voters to complete online postal voter
registrations uh maintaining the use of
the original paper postal voter forms
and I'm pleased that since the online
postal voter registration process began
we have nowed over 100 applications for
poster votes via the online process
unfortunately due to capacity issues
within the Electoral electoral team it
has been it has not been possible to do
any extra work to focus on registration
rates for hard to reach groups uh within
the council's more deprived areas having
said this the efforts of the team as
I've described um are very comprehensive
thank you
thank
you a call upon councilor
scope you have a a
supplementary thank you chair and thank
you Council yakes for that description
um the concern around this just comes
from tracking overtime electoral
registration rates in thanet and
obviously a lot of decisions are made um
we're you know going to be talking later
on about electoral boundaries and we had
the uh boundaries for parliamentary
change recently uh and we want to make
sure as many people are being registered
to vote and it would just be great if we
could um get some assurances as a
council that in the next year or or in
the future that more can be done to
those hard-to-reach areas because those
are the areas where we really want
people to get involved in the political
process thank you I'll call upon
councelor y to respond thank you
councelor scobby and thank you chair um
so the role of the chief executive of
the council is to to um ensure maximum
turnout um so um that's a conversation
that
um I think needs to be responded to by
the chief exec and it'd be inappropriate
for me to speak on his behalf tonight
but I'm sure we can have those
conversations thank you thank
you right agenda item 7B question number
two from Member regarding the Winter
Gardens I call upon councilor warro
thank you chairman good evening uh
Council and good evening to the G engine
Westgate uh Action Group thank you for
coming uh will margate's Winter Gardens
be open for the 2024 summer
season I called upon councelor Duckworth
to respond please thank you
chair and thank you for your question
Council War I'm very pleased to be able
to confirm that the council launched its
marketing campaign to secure a new
partner organization to refurbish and
operate the Gardens for the future we're
working with specialist agents cers to
help us identify the right partner a
partner that shares our vision and
ambition for the Winter Gardens and is
able to demonstrate a viable business
plan for the
future alongside the marketing launch we
have published a Heritage significant
statement which highlights the many
important historical aspects of the
building the enhancement and
preservation of these important Heritage
features is a core part of the vision we
want to see a flexible performance space
that both enhances the Heritage
significance of the buildings and
enables an increase in the numbers of
visitors to the
building marketing campaign launched on
20th November this year and already
attracted a positive response it is a
two-stage process with the initial
expression of Interest stage followed by
the submission of detailed proposals
from a short list of potential partner
organizations
we're looking for expressions of
interest to be submitted by January
2024 and following the assessment of
detailed proposals expect to be in a
position to report the outcome by April
2024 the timeline Beyond 2024 will very
much depend on the details of our
preferred proposal and cannot be
confirmed at this
stage thank you Council Dorth call on
Council War do you have a supplementary
please yes chairman uh thank you
councelor Duckworth on the 8th of
November than District Council confirmed
that the Winter Gardens were being
cleared and the items were being removed
sorry were being sold on auction or by
auction than District Council also
stated and I quote details of the
auction will be made publicly
available however on the 30th of
November it was brought to my attention
that these items had already been sold
so uh councelor Duckworth can you please
tell us uh why the public were not told
about this opt that this uh auction
would take place because it clear they
clearly said that it would would be
mentioned on the website thank you thank
you coun councilor War I call upon
councelor Duckworth to respond
please I'm just I'm just trying to
looking at the dates here so um on the
8th of November it was announced that
there was an
auction um and then obviously sometime
between that date and the 30th they was
they were they were sold um if you don't
feel you you you got the right details
then I'm I'm I don't I don't really know
why why that would be as far as I knew
it was being advertised but um I can
certainly find out for you
thank thank you Council that with agenda
item 7c question number three for the
member regarding improvements of
Boundary Park I call upon councelor
Huxley thank you chair um over three
years ago East cliff wall counselors
discussed updates and improvements to
rams's Boundary Park this is for Council
Alburn one of my fellow
councilors um with improvements in
seating areas for young people and
others enjoying the park as well as
Improv to the playground we note that
the playground swings and safety matting
were replaced recently out of some of
the section 106 monies that would fund
this please can we have an update on
what section 106 monies have been
received what section 106 monies are
still outstanding and when we can expect
this improvement work to be undertaken
thank
you thank you I called upon Council
alurn to
respond thank you chair uh thank you for
the question Council Huxley um just to
advise you then the council has received
16,
p uh from planning reference uh th1
17158 which is to be spent on plate
equipment in Boundary Road although it
should be Boundary Park uh this money
has yet to be spent a total of a further
£3
38,500 has been secured through planning
permissions towards the Boundary Road
play area and is expected to be received
within the next
year a meeting took place with war
councilors in September 2022 to discuss
some of the issues of the park and
options for the Improvement Works using
section 106 funding Works cannot be
programmed until the re the remainder of
the funding has been
received spending the funding in more
than one phase will not offer the best
value for money the head of coastal and
public realm has committed to arrange an
update meeting with counselors from the
district Ward and the Town Council to
discuss the proposals made in 2022 and
update the project process the play
equipment at the park continues to be
inspected in accordance with Roser
guidance and maintenance work will
continue as and when required thank
you thank you council haxley do you have
a supplementary question please yes I do
thanks
chair um I'm glad about the 88p council
album all the that makes all the
difference no it does it's brilliant
that's really good news thank you we
look forward to the next meeting with
officers to discuss the way forward um
supplementary please can he confirm
whether the council will set up a
consultation exercise with local
residents and park users of the Park to
ensure that new facilities provided are
as far as possible in line with what
they would like to see thank
you I'll call Council Alin if you want
to respond yeah thank you
chair yeah thank you chair uh thank you
for the supplementary question councelor
hutley um it's a bit difficult to
actually say yes or no at the present
time um the difficulty is obviously with
the park and notifying residents for
their for their views is that people
come far and why do use the park uh it's
not just in the surrounding areas but uh
I would Al but I would say that I will
take that into con consideration and see
if see if it's possible thank
you thank you agenda item 7D then
question number four from Member
regarding albian Gardens I called upon
councelor critton
thank you
chair this is for councilor Alban again
Ramsgate residents have been
disappointed at the ongoing
deterioration of so much of our heritage
in Ramsgate in particular that the
waterfall in albian gardens has not been
working again this summer can you please
provide an update on progress on
identifying the cause of the leak in the
waterfall at albian Gardens and what is
needed to see it repaired and working
again in time for next summer thank
you called upon councelor alurn to
respond
please yeah thank you chair thank you
councelor cron for your question I'm
also perturbed about the the
waterfall um I can answer as follows the
technical services team has undertaken a
survey of the waterfall they have found
significant defects in the lining of the
pools at the top and the bottom of the
waterfall the team is currently putting
tender documents together to request
quotes for the work by specialist
company the budget estimated for the
works is approximately
£30,000 but this can only be confirm
once the response to the tender
documents has been received thank you
chair thank you I called upon councelor
CR do you have a supplementary I do
thank
you um it's a little concerning that we
actually have two leaks top and bottom
um and uh I was wondering whether or not
we can include uh doing in the in the
tendering quote uh seeking some work
that would do some preventative um work
on the various little bits in between
the top and the
bottom um and I was also wondering
whether or not you're seeking gr funding
although I'm very aware that that might
actually delay the process um so if
those two things could be thought about
thank
you call upon councilor Alber to respond
on yeah thank you chair thank you
Council cron for your supplementary um
what I can say is that um when you refer
for the bits between the top and the
bottom it is the middle so um what I um
what I would say uh what I would say is
um obviously I'm not part of the the
technical team who's who's looking at
the waterfalls but what I can do is take
your concerns on board and I will talk
to the director in relation to that to
see uh whether anything else can be done
thank you chair thank you coun agenda
item 17 question number five from a
member regarding inclusivity of within
parks and Open
Spaces we can all turn over I call upon
councelor Jay
bright thank you chair um I believe my
question is for Council Kean is that
right yeah brilliant um so Recent
research by the Char it makes space for
girls found that girls and young women
use parks and Open Spaces much less than
boys and young men because they don't
feel safe and also because facilities
such as multi-use games areas are not
designed with teenage girls in
mind recent conversations with Secondary
School pupils in broadstairs support
these findings with young people
frequently feeling vulnerable in our
local parks and Open
Spaces public places like permont Park
in broadstairs have a reputation for
antisocial behavior and drug use which
means these spaces are not enjoyed as
much as they should be what can this
council do to ensure our parks and Open
Spaces such as Piermont Park and Jackie
Bakers are more inclusive and inviting
for teenage girls and are made safer for
everyone thank you thank you I call upon
councelor Keane to
respond thank you chair and thank you
for your question councelor bright on
Tuesday at the councilor briefing we
heard from the community team about the
unique work they are undertaking to
tackle the issue of violence against
women and girls and learn about how
unsafe women and girls feel one in two
feel unsafe at night time and one in
three during the day which I think a
shocking
statistics work undertaken by the
partnership is extensive and includes a
lot of proactive campaigns and
interventions such as the introduction
of safe spaces where people can go if
they feel scared or vulnerable ask
Angela Andrew which focuses on licensed
establishments and allows people to ask
for help without drawing attention to
themselves drink spiking campaigns to
alert people to the dangers and how to
protect themselves walk and talk where
the team walk with the neighborhoods
meeting people and talking about safety
safety web page where you can plan your
night out with safety in mind Hotel
watch knife amesty bins and education
self-defense classes ladder of risk all
these things help people understand
behaviors that may be risky and
environmental visual audits on how to
improve areas or all the work that's
being done environmental visual audit
audits do take place and include our
parks and Open Spaces they have
identified issues such as unlit and
overgrown areas which are then rectified
permont park has previously had an audit
and the team continues to work with Kent
Police and within PDC to tackle the
issues raised and identify those who are
causing these areas of concern the
proposed improvements at Jackie Bakers
provides an opportunity to consider and
apply the findings and conclusions from
the January 2023 make space for girls
report along with the experience gained
through the work of the community safety
team it is not acceptable that women and
girls feel unsafe and we will continue
to tackle this officers will continue to
address address concerns reactively as
well as proactively looking at ways to
make our open Open Spaces feel more
inclusive and accessible to women and
girls and we'll be providing more detail
next year as the project progresses
thank you thank you councelor K
councelor Bry do you have a
supplementary question yes I have
ch thank you thank you councelor Kean
for your very detailed response to my
question and I absolutely welcome all
these very reassuring initiatives um we
just need to be better at communicating
this with the public if we want to make
women and girls feel safer in thanet
it's great to hear that there is a help
out there uh but often the people who
need it most don't know what's available
will the council make a coordinated
effort to work more closely with town
and Parish councils Local Schools
Community groups and individual
counselors to ensure information is
shared more widely about what support
and strategies exist and to encourage
better reporting of violence against
women and girls the last couple of days
councilor Christian Bry and I have had
the pleasure of speaking to staff and
over 200 pupils in their class groups at
um Charles Dickens School an amazing
opportunity to reach out and have
important conversations about safety in
our towns a question please sorry um it
would be great if officers and
councilors could work together to share
our knowledge so that we can continue to
have more of these important
conversations across Planet thank you
I call upon councelor Kan to
respond thank you and thank you for the
points you've just made yes I think
you're absolutely right communication is
a key part of this because everyone
needs to know what we're doing and also
for young people and and women and girls
in particular they need to know what is
available out there for them I also
think one of the things that has come up
when I've been looking looking at this
issue is that there is still reluctance
to report violence against women and
girls and I think that's something that
we need to work on so I think we need to
look at communication around this and
really encourage people and make sure
they feel safe to report those concerns
so that we can respond to them thank
you thank you agenda item 7f question
number six for a member regarding
planing application I call upon
councelor Wing thank thank you chair uh
I it's to uh councilor Everett the
leader uh it's not you Steve this time
uh I understand that for a planning
application to be considered by a full
planning committee there needs to be
either a significant number of
objections or a calling by an individual
counselor can you confirm this and are
there any other circumstances when an
application perhaps because of its size
scope and therefore potential negative
impact should automatically be called in
thank you coun councel Wing I call upon
the leader to
respond thank you chair and thank you
councelor wing for your question I was
beginning to feel a bit left out um
actually I don't think this is a
question for me either I think it should
be a question to the chair of the
planning committee but I'm happy to
answer it um applications for planning
permission are primarily determined
under delegated authority by the
planning department which is a necessity
because of the sheer volume of them I
think members are aware in the following
circumstances applications for planning
permission will be determined by the
planning committee if it's an
application which council members have
specifically requested to be referred to
the planning committee in accordance
with the requirements of the members
calling procedure which is set out in
the protocol for the guidance of
planning committee members and officers
contained in the council's Constitution
if it's an application which the head of
Housing and planning or the planning
applications manager in consultation
with the chair or vice chair of the
planning committee considers to be of
significant public interest if the
application has been submitted by or on
behalf of a member or an officer of the
council if it's an app apption by or on
behalf of thanck District Council or on
land owned by than District Council or
by a company to which thanck district
council is a party and finally if it's
an application where the officer is
recommended the approval not in
accordance with the adopted local
plan thank you uh councilor wi do you
have a supplementary yes please uh I
think on the second bit uh leader you
actually said if it's a significant
development so I just wanted to ask the
grid stability plant at Richboro was not
called in it was received in February
and decided by officers in August and
yet sits close to the battery plant and
the convector approved by D by DOA
District Council and now the potential
seink dco proposal does the leader not
think that all future applications in
this area should automatically be called
in given the high potential for negative
cumulative impact and the fact battery
plants known as best plants are fairly
new technologies with considerable fire
and explosion risk as evidenced across
the world you have a question in yeah I
what I'd like to ask that was a question
uh and I'd like to ask uh why the grid
stability plant given that if it's a
considerable uh development of
significant uh public interest why the
grid stability plant wasn't
automatically called in by the planning
committee by uh the
officers and whether all future ones
will be called in can I just interject
as a monitoring officer before councelor
ever answers just to say that it's not
possible to answer specific questions in
relation to an identified planning
application thank you do you want to
respond ler doesn't have to yeah I mean
I I obviously can't comment on the on on
that planning application because as
You' just said the monitoring officer
say and I wouldn't do anyway but I would
say to you councelor Wing there is a
procedure for members of the council to
call in planning applications which they
consider important so any member of the
council presumably could have called it
in they didn't so we can't just rely on
officers we have to take responsibility
and if an individual member of the
council feels that an application is of
particular importance it's up to them to
get in their calling thank
you thank you leader uh agenda item 7 G
question number seven from a member
regarding events and open
spaces and I called upon K brght
counselor K BR thank you chairman um
this question is actually for councelor
Keem um danet Heritage is more than our
many wonderful buildings and spaces my
question is about the much-loved events
that we have in broadstairs and Beyond
the broadstairs folk week Dickens
festival and food festivals bring vital
visitor numbers and income to
broadstairs they're not for profit and
are run by armies of volunteers yet TDC
costs and red tape have increased this
year placing real pressure on the
ongoing survival of these events land
hire charges for broadstairs f food
festival increased by between 223% and
340% year on year this Autumn depending
on which way you look at it broadstairs
folk week has been hit with a 185 %
year-on-year increase in TDC costs
events like these across thanet are
treasured by our residents and must be
protected by increasing costs and
bureaucracy however TDC puts their
ongoing survival in doubt what steps can
be taken to ensure we have a fair
approach to charging these events for
the use of our Open Spaces thanks thank
you councelor can I call upon councelor
Kain to
respond thank you chair and thank you
Council Bride for your
question
the importance of well-run events on the
tourism and local economy is recognized
by TDC which is why we have an events
policy suitability of events document
and a range of suitable sites for events
across the district the fees and charges
for events are based on their category
and size the number of visitors the
categories include enthusiasts
specialist interest subjects such as
reenactments charity Regional or
national commercial provides a
commercial benefit to profit making
businesses such as food festivals or
concerts community directly benefiting
residents and visitors such as social
groups or Village Fates active
Recreation running Etc and the armed
forces the categories are not based on
the status of those organizing them but
the event itself the categories and fees
can be found on our website in some
cases as events become more popular and
attract more visitors then they will
move up the fee structure this year we
have undertaken an audit of our event
applications to ensure that we are
correctly applying our fees and charges
in some cases events have previously
been undercharged which would explain an
increase or the number of attendees has
increased explaining the increase the
events policy and suitability of events
were formally adopted by thanet District
Council in 2021 for 3 years when they
will be reviewed the charges are revised
yearly as part of the fees and charges
process and then agreed by
Council thank you have you Council K BR
have you a supplementary question please
I do chair um thanks uh counc Kean for
your um your detailed response um it
seems to me that it's entirely possible
for some of our events to become victims
of their own success um the fact that
for example food The Folk Festival is
really successful um doesn't make it
easier to run um and the administrative
burden I still think uh still seems
excess uh excessive um as a council
could we discuss solutions to help
rather than hinder the organizers of
such events perhaps via the creation of
a new cultural or Heritage category of
event in order to Signal TDC support for
their continued
success thank you I call on Council Kan
to
respond thank you the contract will be
or the policy will be coming up for
renewal in 2024 it's an excellent time
to look at these issues um I think we
sort of have to accept with the
administration for events that we have a
duty to keep the public safe and as um
there are health and safety expectations
sometimes this does increase the amount
of paperwork that is required but I
think one thing we can do is look at how
we can support those organizing the
event
so that we can help them to do that
thank
you right thank you so agenda item 78
question number eight from Members
regarding River o manston airport this
will be the last question so called upon
councilor
fellows thank you uh Mr chairman Mr
chairman as we all know the fruitless
challenges to the reopen of and the
largest investment opportunity ever to
come to thanet are shortly coming to an
end so Mr chairman I'd like to ask the
leader can he confirm that he has
received an invite from rther Oak and he
has a meeting booked in his diary to
meet with the owners of manston to hear
the plans for the
airport thank you I called upon the
leader to
respond thank you councilor fellas and
to those who are disappointed they're
not going to hear the answers to their
questions I might find a way to get that
into the leader's report where they
address to me um uh well actually I
invited Mr freudman to come to a meeting
with me he didn't invite he didn't send
an invite to me um and um yes I can
confirm that together with senior
officers I will be meeting him next week
to um hear about his plans um I look
forward to that I would have liked to
have done it earlier unfortunately it
wasn't possible to coordinate Diaries um
there were offers made to Mr fman of an
earlier date he wasn't able to do that
we weren't able to do some later dates
and it's not just my diary and his diary
but we have arrived at a date that we
can both do and that's going to be next
week thank
you thank you call upon Council fell
have you supplementary I do Mr chairman
thank you uh I think it's important that
all members get to hear the plans for
Manon so Mr chairman I'd like to ask the
leader if he will come back to the next
full Council on the 8th of February with
a separate agenda item report to us his
findings of his
meeting Le a response yeah I mean I
don't think members should have to wait
until the 8th of February to to hear
what what goes on on the meeting and I'm
perfectly happy to communicate with
members in the meantime um and there
will be other opportunities of to engage
with Mr fudman and RSP in the mean time
of which I'm aware so I don't think
that's a problem but I don't think we
want to wait until the until February in
fact I think that's budget Council
anyway so I wouldn't be able to make
such a
report right thank you so everybody else
hasn't had a question answered they get
it in writing so we're moving on to
agenda item 7 m
question
is that
right item eight notice of motion for
notice of motion have been received in
accordance with the council procedure
rule
three please note the time allowed for
consideration of motions shall not
exceed 30 minutes as per the rules
outlined in the council's
Constitution I ask members to be suent
in Poss any as possible any motions that
are not dealt with within the 30 minutes
time limit will be rolled forward to the
next
ordinary meeting of council at this
point I would like to amend the order
that the council consider notice of
motion as agenda item C is time
sensitive due to closure of forthcoming
consultation I therefore propose to
suspend Council procedure rule 3.3 this
will allow me to change the order that
Council considers the motion that
tonight's meeting Mee is there a
second good do members agree members
agree do we all
agree okay right thank you I therefore
going to item 8 C not of the motion
regarding National Grid seag link
project prior to item 8 B no notice of
motion regarding abuse of counselors and
officers this one first that one
first this one y right sorry I'm this is
my place agenda item 8 I not as a motion
regarding Manson airport and Rivero I'll
call upon councelor
warro thank you
chair K KY Council Canterbury swell and
labor Le do Council have all had
presentations from River o the fact that
thanet counselors have been invited to
visit the airport is no sub Institute
for a presentation in the council
chambers live on the internet for
residents to
see I move the
motion as the democratically elected
representatives of the people of thanet
we recognize that the time has come for
us to put our political differences
aside and to acknowledge that we are
Duty bound to welcome with open arms the
inward
investment that is so crucial to the
economic
growth necessary in order to create the
jobs needed for our children and
grandchildren manston airport is a vital
concern to the local
residents therefore it is in the
interest of
everyone living in thanet to hear the
current proposals of Rivero strategic
partners and for us as their District
councilors to put our words into
action and as previously mentioned to
invite Tony freudman and the River Oak
team to make a presentation to the full
Council which is to be an extraordinary
meeting no later than the 1st of
March
2024 thank you chairman thank you is
there a second secondly
chair
controlling political group is entitled
to reply I call upon
councelor thank you chair thank you uh
councelor War for your motion um as I've
just explained I'll be meeting Mr
freudman next week with senior officers
and I think one of the things that we'll
want to discuss is RP's um intentions
about engaging with counselors in
addition I'm aware that the political
groups have been invited to visit the
airport for a tour and a question and
answer session I assume that includes
your group councelor War um I've said
before um that I'm very happy to invite
Mr freudman to come to the council um
and talk to members at one of our um
members briefings as he did indeed two
years ago though it was online because
of covid I think
um Mr fman is also obviously perfectly
capable of engaging with the public uh
at the airport or any other way he
chooses to explain what his plans is
I don't think that um on top of all
these things we actually need an
extraordinary Council which incurs
additional costs um well over and above
the cost of a members briefing um and is
governed by procedure rules um which
would make it difficult for the meeting
to function in the way that perhaps
members would like which is not the case
at members briefings Council meetings um
are for discussing Council business and
making
decisions uh members are not being asked
to make any decisions about the airport
so for that reason I will not be
supporting your motion as I don't
believe that such a meeting will be
necessary or appropriate thank
you would members please note that in
accordance with Council procedure rule
3.7 it is not agreed to debate the
motion it will fall as only the council
can agree the
motion can I have a proposer and a
second to debate the
motion and
second
do members
agree do we want do we want to age so we
don't want to have a vote have a vote
can we have a show of hands please
certainly yes so those in favor of
debating the motion those in favor of
debating the motion please raise your
hand
those
against sorry point point of order chair
has he voted twice just
his
anybody abstaining any any abstentions
you put your hands down
sorry can we just do it again
extensions
okay so motion is lost
right agenda item 8C notion of motion
notion of
emotion regarding National Grid seed
link projects I call upon councelor
Everett thank you chair um I will start
by reading the motion um Council
acknowledges the considerable public
concern over the impacts of National
Grids seink project which is currently
the subject of a saty consultation
process we share this concern and wish
to reassure residents that their views
are heard and understood we recognize
the need to adapt the electricity
transmission Network in order to respond
to Rising demand and the move to
sustainable generation methods in new
locations we welcome the extensive
engagement by National Grid with both
elected members and the communities in
thanet most affected Council agrees that
it does have major concerns regarding
the proposed location on Minster marshes
the scale of the converter building as
well as the effects of the associated
infrastructure the significant impact on
protected wildlife and species habitat
both during construction and afterwards
and the potential change to the
character of the landscape while this
council is not a decision maker in
respect to this development we commit to
making and Publishing a formal response
to the current consultation that
highlights these issues and our concerns
about
them um and to be clear I brought this
motion to the council because it is
clearly a matter of considerable public
interest um and I do share some of the
concerns being
expressed um because this is a a
statutory
consultation and it is leading to a
development consent order and not a
planning application it's not for us to
decide the
outcome um but what this also means is
that there would have been no
opportunity for the council to express
its views in public in the in the way
that I hope we can tonight and I think
that's
essential um the council's Constitution
requires the uh consultation response to
be delegated to officers however it will
be informed by our policies and I know
that officers are listening to our views
in framing that response and everybody
will see it cuz it will will be
published I'm not an expert in
electricity Supply infrastructure you'll
be surprised to hear uh and I don't feel
equipped to argue about the need for
such a development I am clear about the
harm the scheme will potentially cause
if it goes ahead in this location and in
the way set out but this motion is
framed um for the whole Council to be
able to support it and to provide a
platform for debate for members so that
they can express their views and that
the public can hear them loud and clear
I move the motion thank you
is there a
second
okay the controlling political group is
entitled to reply however us there being
a motion from the controlling political
group The Leader has offered the
response to the leader of the opposition
and I have
agreed therefore I called upon
councelor thank you chair and I I thank
uh the leader for allowing me to respond
to this I was looking forward to him
trying to respond back to his own motion
really I would have paid good money to
see that he do talk himself a lot he
does it does counc I know you can attest
to that
um I'd first uh like to add in joining
and agreeing with much of what uh
Council rever has said tonight
particularly about the proposals for
seink put forward by the National Grid I
know there's a lot of ANS and concern
within the community on the potential uh
impact on the environment and on the not
just the Minster marshes but the wider
area as well that these proposals will
bring and I know that sir Roger Gil has
been engaging quite hard with government
and ministers and with National Grid to
try and find not just an alternative
site uh but a solution um to those
proposals uh the National Grid is seeing
an unprecedented demand in Not Just
Energy
Generation Um right Council Ms you can
chip in if you want um National Grid is
seeing an unprecedented demand in not
just uh energy generation from from
power plants but also in moving that
energy around the country and as we move
to Net Zero um and more people are
encouraged to purchase electric vehicles
uh that uh need for electricity will not
just double but it will triple we're
currently not generating nowhere near
the amount of energy that we need to uh
for everyone to be able to have an
electric car that currently has a petrol
car um and because of that and I
appreciate the motion being brought
forward we will be uh supporting this
motion tonight thank
you thank you would members please note
that in accordance with the council
procedure rule
3.7 if it is not agreed to debate the
motion it will fall only as Council this
motion can I have a proposal and a
second to debote the motion opposed coun
coun you proposing it a
second that's come for reason
that's do members agree to debote the
motion okay right so who wants to start
oh councilor
Davis thank you chair um I just want to
uh thank the leader for bringing this
motion because this is probably one of
the biggest issues despite what people
claim about other matters I think this
is one of the biggest issues and an
extent threat to this community that
we've seen for a long time um the
passion is also visible in the gallery
there are members of The Campaign and I
think it would be easy to be conflicted
potentially on this because we do need a
more robust grid and there is obviously
a need for that with the headlong rush
for electric and we won't get into the
Rights and Wrongs of that in this debate
um what I would like to see and or
implore if we could include a as well as
saying what we don't want it's always
good principle to give an alternative
and to say what you do want or to find a
solution because there's clearly I mean
there's a lot of suspicion that this is
a done deal because the infrastructure
is plowing in and you know there's a
point of no return we come to so I was
very pleased to see also mitigation
measures being discussed by the
campaigners but as s Roger Gale uh MP
has said there are alternatives and in
fact there is a an international link
being laid as we speak between the who
Peninsula which is where King's North
Power Station a Brownfield site is
located and Germany who Peninsula is
therefore proven as a as a suitable
Landing site for subc cabling could I
suggest that this Council adopts perhaps
a s or implores National Grid to look at
an alternative because there is probably
very good fiscal reason Reasons I'm sure
on their part as a private company but
this Marsh when it's lost is lost it's
one of the last wild areas in East Kent
it's in massively important to migrating
birds and the history of what the pylons
that have been there before have done to
migrating birds 179 swans I think speaks
for itself this is an environmental
disaster potentially I would not want to
live down there anymore or in the area
because where's the water going to go
from 22 Acres of runoff there this is a
poorly thought out selfishly planned
project and I think we need to not only
stand against it but to try and find
positive suggestions work with our MPS
and try and force National Grid to
consider a more viable alternative
ecologically thank you thank
you call upon Council
maners uh thank you chair um it's rare
for us to come into this room and find
ourselves all in agreement um and it's
it's very good to see that there is
cross party support for this um I can't
help but fear that if we were in Seven
Oaks um that this wouldn't have even got
in the starting block but because we're
a relatively poorer um less prosperous
uh area of Kent um there's perhaps a
hope that people in Kent in this part of
Kent are too busy working to pay their
mortgages or God forbid too lumpen to
get agitated about this so I'm pleased
that uh members are taking the lead um I
fully support us working cross party to
uh get as much publicity to expose
what's being proposed here we're we're
talking about the loss of the last
Wilderness Area in thanet uh and I think
it it can't stand thank you thank you
now call upon councilor
wing
thank you chair is good that I'm not
going to comment on anything that said
before because I think we're in full
agreement but having helped organize uh
a series of meetings across the whole of
thanet so Minster uh sandwich we went
into DOA because obviously some of the
developments out of Richboro are on the
DOA District side uh it's going to
impact a amazingly badly on biodiversity
and I you know the government needs to
look at uh not just tackling the big end
of the problem but looking at the small
end of the problem so perhaps if we
could de decarbonize houses and
encourage people to not buy new cars
then we wouldn't be sat in the situation
of increasing demand that that
constantly fed one of our main concerns
is the flooding issue so this building
will take up 22 football pitches the run
that that piece of land will no longer
soak water up it's already wet most of
the Year down there but once you've got
the the 22 football pitches and the
runoff off of those 22 football pitches
then I really do fear for our friends
who live in Minster uh I also worry
about the cumulative impact because like
I said in my question we have the
battery plant which is new technology
fire and explosion risk which the fire
brigade and if you just Google get best
plants you'll see there's incident after
incident across the world there's no
British standard for those plants there
we've also got the grid stability plant
which is taking up the space where the
weather leaves treatment plant which is
stretched we know that that that that
plant can't deal with the sewage that's
already been produced mainly from
Minster uh so I have huge concerns about
that location there it's important to
realize that all of these things are
being built on land which is no more
than 3 m above sea level most of it at
or just slightly above sea level we've
got rising sea levels come we've already
got flood defenses we've already nearly
had a a major flooding incident in
sandwi
so I I fully support this council's uh
move to to address some of the serious
concerns that we have if this thing ends
up on our patch thank you thank
you call upon councelor
Smith I thank you lead thank you Council
oh goodness thank you chair thank you
leader I'm um I'm just generally
grateful I I I don't what there's left
for me to say except a few sort of witty
quips but it's not funny this is our
this is our and to quote Nick Mitchell
our last bit of wild it's the last bit
of actual Wilderness in thanet we've
allowed massive development to take
place across our district and we've seen
in the time that I've been a counselor
for the villages we've seen radical
transformation of those
communities and this adds major injury
to
insult so I really hope that we are able
to express ourselves our
Terror at the the incursion into our
natural environment
that this represents but by the same
token as um councelor Davis pointed out
we need to make sure that we engage
constructively because we need to get as
much from this if it's going to go ahead
we've got to make sure that we get as
much mitigation and meaningful
mitigation
um I I would point to the example of the
the battery storage plant
which um involved the removal of an
historic wind turbine in which there
were Ravens at paragr nesting for many
years to schedule one
species and uh
um I think it's sheath energy whoever um
said that it had provided compensatory
habit habitat in the for form of a in
platform on a specific perigrine Tower
which was welcome not the Ravens
obviously uh but the platform was
constructed to face into the prevailing
wind so it was no earthly use or skyly
use to the birds and and no further
mitigation was offered so was oh sorry
has appeared so my point is can we we
cannot afford to trust large private
utilities to look up after our interests
or the interests of our Irreplaceable
Wildlife that's all I'm going to say
thank you thank
you councelor k brigh please something
thank you chair um I'm kind of
regretting standing up now because
everyone everyone has spoken so
eloquently and passionately about this
and I'm I'm really encouraged that
members across the chamber are in in
Broad agreement um it it actually
Beggars belief anyone thought this was a
good idea to build on Wetlands um
Council Davis's point about once they're
gone they're gone with these species um
I fully support the council's uh the
motion today thank you to councelor
Everett for bringing it um I've not
really got much to add other than this
is a crime um and we need to be treating
it as such when we communica with
National Grid thank
you councelor will scobby please thank
you chair um just a couple of points to
add um just responding to councelor
manners I think if a c link was going
into Seven Oaks it probably would be
rejected but that might because it
doesn't have a coast um not sure under
under CK we going but I take the
point um they won't go quietly correct
correct I I certainly take the point um
one thing I do think um does need to be
pointed out here um is that this will be
going as a dco to national government
for decision on this so Council Davis is
Right engaging with the local MPS is
going to be quite important one point of
concern that I think we probably do need
to look out on this is it clearly has
the government support these sort of
schemes buried in the Autumn statement
from the uh Chan of the ex Checker was a
point around financially incentivizing
communities that are being disrupted by
this and there will be 10 years worth of
payments which leads me to think that um
despite the unanimity that we've got
here there's probably some political
considerations at a national level that
means this is unfortunately is going to
happen um and I just hope that um if we
are communicating that that via
colleagues and maybe even a future
government of a different stripe May
listen thank you very
much okay thank you is anybody else want
to okay on
then thank you chair um I just wanted to
say that this year members may have um
be aware that we had the state of nature
report which showed again significant
declines in
ecosystems and we've had that in 2013
we've had that in 2016 and we had that
in
2019 so we have continuous decline of
biodiversity we have a climate change
and ecological crisis we don't we
shouldn't be just talking about carbon
and dealing with carbon issues we have
to look at things in a more full system
thinking
way you know and just to trash an
environment like this shows that really
governments are not really interested or
do not recognize the value that
biodiversity has and I would like to
bring to me Members attention Tony
Juniper's book what has nature ever done
for us nature provides us with loads of
services that we have the privilege to
have we are jeopardizing those Services
by behaving the way we are so we need to
look
alternative U places for this I believe
off the coast of Belgium they use an
Offshore platforms to actually uh deal
with this issue and I would like to see
this as a consideration to be put
forward as well I I appreciate that TDC
aren't in a position to be able to make
the ultimate decision and it's great as
as as a leader has done has put this
motion forward but I would really really
urge people to recognize we're in a
climate change and ecological crisis on
that site there are red listed species
curus which are in really really bad
State there are turtle doves there are
um skylars there are
Nightingales these are valuable to not
to mention all the amphibian
and all the Flora they deserve a right
to live too this planet isn't just about
people it's about other creatures too
and we should have the privilege to care
and nurture and look after this planet
so please please can we have the council
put a more stronger um urge towards a
different approach to resolving this
issue thank
you thank you
Council
Austin thank you chair um I'd like to
support what everybody has said and I
would like to urge
individual yourselves to this
consultation as well as the council
responding the more of us who respond
and make the sorts of points that we've
talked about this evening the more
weight it will have thank
you
right I call upon the C the councilor
ever to read out the wording of the
motion once again
please I got to find it again now
CH Council acknowledges the considerable
public concern over the impacts of
National Grid seic project which is
currently the subject of a straty
consultation process
we share this concern and wish to
reassure residents that their views are
heard and understood we've recognized
the need to adapt the electricity
transmission Network in order to respond
to Rising demand and the move to
sustainable generation methods in new
locations we welcome the extensive
engagement by National Grid with both
elected members and the communities and
Planet most affected Council agrees that
it does have major concerns regarding
the proposed location on Minster marshes
the scale of the converter building as
well as the effects of the associated
infrastructure the significant impact on
protecting wildlife and species habitat
both during construction and afterwards
and the potential change to the
character of the landscape while this
council is not a decisionmaker in
respect to this development we commit to
making and Publishing a formal response
to the current consultation that
highlights these issues and our concerns
about them thank
you thank
you we shove hands please those for the
motion
yes those against then
any any
abstentions no it's agreed then
thank that's the end of the 30 minutes
thank you so we now go on to agenda item
nine leaders report a a call upon the
Le
thank you
chair members are
ready so at the risk of upsetting
councelor alurn I want to start tonight
by congratulating Ramsgate football club
on reaching the second round of the FA
Cup and gaining National media attention
in the process with a game at Wimbledon
on Monday being broadcast on itv4
featured on BBC breakfast about the town
on Satan as well as other positive
national and local coverage I was
delighted to join 1500 Ramsgate
supporters at plow Lane on Monday it has
to be said unfortunately that Wimbledon
were just too good on the night but
there is no shame in going out in the
second round of the FA Cup to a league
side if you're a team playing in the
eighth tier of the football pyramid it's
a bit different going out to team in
League 2 if you're playing in League one
we'll pass over there I'm sure people in
Ramsgate andth and everyone at the club
will remember Monday night's occasion
for years to come and the club can be
very proud of their
achievement I know that councelor alour
would like me to point out that Margate
where he's a director reached the third
round in 1973 and played Spurs at home
but unlike him I'm not old enough to
remember that we did it first in the
interest of brevity I am mostly not
going to cover any support subjects that
already been raised in questions and
motions on the agenda so apologies to
anybody who wanted to hear more about
the war pole Bay tidal pool in
particular however as I promised I will
deal with some of the
questions if
uh bear with me that we didn't get to um
I think the first one was councelor
Roger question about the recruitment of
a casework officer um the of a casew
work officer uh is a proposal in the
draft 2425 budget um that budget is
currently out for consultation and has
not been put before members for voting
yet it will come back to Council in
February um in the meantime work has
been done by the monitoring officer to
finalize an initial draft of a revised
Council officer protocol which sets out
clear guidance and expectations for
relationships between councilors and
officers including in Sharing relevant
information and this will be presented
for counselors to counselors for further
consider ation in the New Year by the
Constitution review working party um
councilor Braidwood asked whether the
Westgate on SE neighborhood plan will be
taken into account in consideration of
any planning applications that might
happen to be around in respect of
Westgate and Garing and I can tell him
that the answer is yes um councelor
Davis asked
whether the situation with Stratford
house and wouth house in mgate
central um involved a TDC building
inspection I can tell him that TDC did
not carry out the building inspection
under relevant building control
legislation construction can be signed
off by private sector approved
inspectors independently of the local
Authority and that was the case with
both statford house and wouth house um
this legislation in my opinion is a load
of rubbish and should be reviewed I
think local authorities should be
responsible and local authorities can
then be held
accountable uh he also asked about
whether it was considered in the
planning process I
think yeah um issues relating to the
construction including subsidence
whether caused by ground conditions or
inadequate foundations are not matters
considered by the national planning
regime there are no planning Powers
available to the council to enable it to
intervene um however obviously the
council has um looked at this situation
with some concern has met with um
Southern housing and is doing as much as
it can to offer support to the residents
to find alternative
homes I think that's as far as I'm going
to
get go back to the
report
um I do want to talk tonight about the
future of the manston site currently
used as a migrant processing center on
September the 20th officers and I met
officials from the home office to
discuss their future plans for the
facility following reports in the media
we were assured that while the
government was looking to looking at
making some some of the 10 structures
there permanent in order to provide a
more efficient and satisfactory
operation there were no plans to
increase the scale or vary the use of
the site the home office also undertook
to keep us updated about any changes to
these plans consequently we were very
unhappy to hear via Kent County Council
of plans to create a migrant removal
Center on the site I've been the aing
with the north fet MP sir Roger G on
this matter and indeed it was this
Council that fed the information back to
him that is not only discourteous to us
as elected representatives it is
disrespectful to the people of thanet
on November the 20th I wrote to the then
immigration Minister Robert genrich
setting out this council's
dissatisfaction with the handling of the
matter and asking for a further meeting
to discuss our concerns I have today put
this letter in the public domain because
it is my view that residents are
entitled to know about these plans and
this council's position as the local
planning authority to be clear this is
not an issue about the Rights and Wrongs
of immigration policy and of course
Robert genrich resigned on Tuesday and I
doubt it was in process about what's
happening at manston
it is about the principle of the
government seeking to impose a
high-profile and inevitably
controversial facility in our district
without engaging with local
representatives and indeed apparently
misleading
them I recently met representatives of
fisa following the announcement of 500
likely job losses at Discovery Park in
Sage it's likely that many of these
employees live in thanet and there could
be further impacts on other businesses
that support activities which fiser is
planning to discontinue further meetings
are plan anticipated with do and
Canterbury councils to see if there are
any ways in which we can work together
to support those
affected turning to more positive news I
am really pleased that we've been able
to kick off the search for an operas
over the Winter Gardens and I hope the
members have had a chance to review the
extensive Heritage significance
statement which gives a really
fascinating insight into the building's
history I have said publicly and I'm
happy to reiterate that the council will
not allow the building or the site to be
used for housing and we are not offering
it for sale on a freehold basis our
ambition for the winter Gardens is to
restore it to its former glory protect
it for leisure use and as a performance
space while being open to any other
ideas that may come forward alongside
that to support its future viability and
as an illustration of the public
interest in this project a single social
media post about the Winter Gardens by
the comms team recently reached
125,000 people which is more than the
adult population of
thanet we've also received the green
light to make a 3.2 million bid to the
National Lottery Heritage fund for the
theater Royal and a public engagement
session to share and receive feedback on
the plans took place this afternoon and
I can tell you that by 5:00 there have
been about 150 visitors to that and uh I
think officers regarded that as being uh
very successful and they did say that
there wasn't hadn't been one person
who'd come and raised any um complaint
about what was proposed it was a very
enthusiastic and um a warm approach to
the building and the plans so that's
quite encouraging members will be aware
that the council was recently taken
possession of the clock house in
Ramsgate following the surrender of the
previous lease that is an important step
forward on one of our big leveling up
fund projects and in safeguarding the
building's future continuing the
Heritage theme councelor dwor and I
recently visited Margate Museum the
tuler house and the Dickens house in
broadstairs with officers these are all
important assets and I look forward to
having further discussions about ways we
can make them more accessible and
attractive to visitors and residents
councilors dwor Keane and I were also
pleased to have the opportunity of a
tour around br's College site last
Thursday and see the impressive range of
facilities available there including
Cutting Edge digital technology it's
clear that the college is providing
valuable opportunities to local young
people and deserves our support a week
earlier around 150 representatives from
local community and volunteer groups
came together to attend our community
Champions conference at St Augustines in
Westgate to hear about how we plan to
distribute our allocation of 1.15
million from the shared Prosperity
Grant I was proud to represent the
council at the annual remembrance Sunday
service in broadstairs on November the
12th and I should compliment broadstairs
Town Council on its efficient
organization up to an including making
sure the rain held off just to the point
that it ended I know the chair and chief
executive at the simultaneous event in
Margate and that the deputy leader was
at the one in
Ramsgate the severe weather emergency
protocol was activated last weekend and
I'd like to thank everyone involved with
the rise team's efforts to get rough
sleepers into temporary emergency
accommodation at mme
Hall I'm delighted that next week
cabinet will be considering the AC
position of a further 24 section 106
affordable homes this time in Tot Hill
Street
Minster taking the total added to the
council's housing stock in the six
months of this
Administration to
92 we will also be moving forward on
works at Jackie Bakers honoring the
commitments we made to the petitioners
at the last council meeting and I'm
pleased that we can now share the draft
master plan of the site sitting
alongside the things we need to do now
we'll also to do some research on the
correct spelling of its name which I
know concerns councelor Davis but I'm
sure like me he's well used to having
his name spell
wrong the same meeting will also
consider the first phase of our plans to
address the backlog of work required to
our public toilets with at least 1.25
million of work set out and significant
repairs taking place this winter ahead
of next year's tourist season we're
planning for new and additional
provision at Stone Bay marget Clock
Tower and importantly botney Bay it's a
start but we need to do more and find
ways to address the concerns repeatedly
expressed to all of us about opening
hours this plan is long overdue and I
want to thank all the officers who
worked hard to get it ready in time for
last night's overview and scrutiny
committee so that members there could
review and comment before the decision
is made by cabinet that in turn is part
of our administration's commitment to
transparency and I did watch a recording
of the meeting last night I believe this
additional process adds value and we
will take into account scrutinous
comments when cabinet makes its
decisions next week
there is a huge amount going on across
this organization whatever political
group you may be in I hope you can feel
proud of at least some of the efforts
the council is making on behalf of our
residents I wish you all a merry
Christmas and I believe that 2024 will
be a year in which we will continue to
make good progress towards our share
vision for
[Applause]
than thank you can I call upon councilor
Pew comment or ask questions please
thank you chair uh thly I'd like to
thank the leader for advanced sight of
uh his report um and as always it was
quite an extensive report um of course I
share the sentiments of the leader in
saying well done to to Ram football club
um in not just getting so far uh into
the FA Cup uh but also the great work
that they do within the community and
and within wider public groups and I
think it demonstrates uh not just the
success of RAM football club but the
needs for us all to support Grassroots
Sports and football um and I know the
leader referen Jackie Bakers uh which
I'll I'll ask a question on a bit later
as
well um I appreciate the leader's
comments on the Manon home office
facility I was a little bit confused by
the phrase that he used um I hope that
I've mised con student I've got it wrong
and that he wasn't uh stating that sir
Roger Gil would misled uh residents on
the plans for the uh changes to the
facility I hope that's not the case um I
know that sir Roger Gail uh will be
meeting soon with the Home Secretary uh
to discuss this um and not to directly
quote him but wild speculation I think
is quite irresponsible so I do think
that we need to be careful um and seek
to understand and find out exactly
what's going on and what future plans
there may or may not be moving on to the
winter GS in theater role I'm delighted
as I know the leader is and we all
probably are here um that the brochure
um has gone public uh for expressions of
Interest for the Winter Gardens it's a
much treasured uh asset and and building
an entertainment venue as is the theat
to role for many of us with in the
community and I know that people are
Keen to see it uh to be opened and
reopened so that we can enjoy both of
them again the only question I have of
of the leader is that particularly not
just with the winter guns and the
theater allw but with other assets that
we hold and I know that the leader
referenced visiting along with councilor
Duckworth the marget museum and the
Dickens Museum and other um areas is
that if um Su operator cannot be found
for the Winter Gardens or even the
theater O as well because I take no
bones in saying that we as counselors
and particularly offices are potentially
not experts in running entertainment
venues is that if operators cannot be
found what then do the venues sit empty
uh do they sit there and left to rot and
and crumble um I know from my time as
Deputy leader of the council we took the
Heritage Minister around the Winter
Gardens and it's of course a very uh
special building and there's a lot of
unique features to that building it
would be a real shame if we can't
identify a suitable operator that can
deliver it and it's then just left still
closed whether as councilor War had
referenced earlier we've sold all the
the prize China and silver and
everything in
between moving on to the ram clock house
I am delighted I think everyone will be
delighted uh that the clock house has
now come back into possession of the
council I know that was a very long
thought campaign and it's something the
officers have been working on for quite
some time so it is is an
achievement um the shared Prosperity
fund and the conference that was held
last week um it's incredibly encouraging
that so many Community groups attended
that conference uh to hear about the
potential for access to funds from the
shares pracy fund I've already voiced my
concerns to officers that Council has
weren't able to attend I appreciate that
numbers were tight but hopefully going
forward and I'd like to hope that the
leader will commit uh to ensuring that
councilors are able to attend these
events and conferences because
counselors are a vital link between not
just residents but Community groups and
the council and particularly with the
shared Prosperity fund and the uh
potential that that has uh forth anic
and we're incredibly lucky to have um
received funding for that it's really
important that councilors are involved
in that and I know that there were
counselors probably not just on within
my group but within other political
groups as well um that were being asked
by Community groups about the shared
Prosperity fund and what it means and
also and I don't expect the leaders to
confirm this now but also that um groups
will not be dissuaded from applying for
Grants um I've heard from groups that
attended the conference and of course I
wasn't there nor were any other
counselors so of course it's secondhand
information that they've been told that
particularly local Scout groups that
they need not apply for shared
Prosperity funding uh because the
funding is more suitable to uh
entrepreneurs and entrepreneur on people
that are entrepreneurial that will be
creating jobs now Community groups and
volunteer groups such as the local Scout
groups do an immeasurable amount of work
within the community and I say that as
and I declare an interest that my
in-laws are part of a local Scout group
and my wife was a scout leader for some
time but I know how much they do in the
the local community area even if my son
I did take my son to there Santa's
Grotto last weekend and he was
absolutely terrified by Santa but that's
another thing so I hope that the leader
can confirm that of course everyone
would be welcome to apply um including
these Community groups that work with a
lot of young people in the local area
I'm delighted to hear that the leader
attended the remembrance Sunday service
apologies chair I will be quick um
attended the remembrance Sunday services
and that there were representatives from
the councils at big events I think and I
was attending the Burton remembrance uh
celebrate parade um I think it shows
thaning at its best really and I think
it's something that we do really well
and I'm delighted that people were able
to attend um just very quickly and I
will be quick Jackie Bakers uh the
proposals for the new facilities at
Jackie Bakers um are welcome they're
welcome for the community but I did
notice that going back to Ramsgate
football club and Grassroots football
that there will be less uh football
pitches and Facilities on the grounds I
know from my own experience that many uh
local youth clubs uh use that for white
quite large scale tournaments so I'd
hope that that won't be the case and
they won't be restricted in using Jackie
Bakers um similar to the announcement of
the public toilets I'm hoping the leader
can confirm that it was mentioned
previously um within the announcement
that there will be some Southern water
funding and I'd be quite interested to
hear precisely what that is where that's
come from um and how that will will be
used um and finally although this is
probably going to be a long meeting and
it'd be great to see everyone for a mint
pie later but we're not going to do that
I would like to wish everyone a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New
Year thank
you called upon the leader to
respond yeah thanks Council Pew um I I
had to deliver that in rather faster
than I intended because I wanted to get
the answers and so perhaps I confuse the
situation slightly around sir Roger um
I've been talking to Sir Roger and the
oing with s Roger um on this issue for a
while as I think he's aware um I
absolutely um I'm not accusing sir Roger
of anything um sir Roger I think has the
same has concerns about what what may or
may not be going on at um at manston in
the same way that we do um it happens
that we've been party to uh as a council
to information from Kent County Council
which um and I don't want to speak for
him but he hasn't been party to um he's
tried to get meetings with um Robert jri
and I understand he he hoped to meet Ro
Robert jenrick last week and that didn't
happen so he's not been able to get an
answer we've got information which um
supports what we're saying um but if sir
Roger um Can discover that none of this
is going to happen and it's all a pipe
dream and K County Council have made it
up or we've imagined it then I'm sure
we'd be delighted um but I'm certainly
not accusing him this honestly we're
working quite happily together um as far
as the Winter Gardens is concerned um
I'm not planning for failure um we have
some ideas about what we might do if we
don't get um if we don't get what we
want in this uh
particular um marketing exercise but I
think we'll wa and see what comes back
before we go down that road but we will
certainly not be giving up on our
Ambitions uh for the Winter Gardens
whatever the response is um and that
goes to the other venues um there was a
briefing on Tuesday on the Shar
Prosperity fund which all councils were
invited to um and that was quite an
extensive briefing um I think one of the
one of the things which came out of the
conference was that we need to find ways
for Community groups to be able to work
more closely with counselors don't think
having 56 counselors or inviting 56
counselors to be in the room lastly or
even as we suggested a small number
would have been effective
um there isn't a plan to reduce the
number of football pitches at Jackie
Bakers the uh artwork in the in the
document is an illustration and it's for
consultation so all those things will be
taken into account um I think the
southern water money issue was fully
explored at scrutiny last night council
cup was there so I'm sure he can fill
him in thank
you thank you uh call upon councelor
gner to comment or ask questions in
relation to the leader's report
please thank you very much thanks as
always to the leader for early sight of
his report to enable me to write this
response I'm sure lots of us watched
Ramsgate play Wimbledon on Monday where
to be fair they were well beaten by a
good League one team despite this the
whole team League what league two
team despite this they'll soon be in
League one despite this the whole team
could be proud of their performance to
get as far as they did and as the leader
alluded to um to fall in the same round
as the mighty Chon athletic is no mean
feet we walk we welcome the fact that
the search and operator for the Winter
Gardens has kicked off and agree with
your objective to restore it to its
former glory and protect it for leisure
use this is as it should be Planet needs
a major venue to attract major comedy
and music acts all year round as well as
being able to host other community
community events we sh certainly share
the leaders concerns about the home
offices plans for the manston Detention
Facility and think you were correct to
write to the now ex immigration minister
to express those concerns on our behalf
we as a group have been long deeply
troubled about conditions people have
been held in at the camp in the past and
have seen nothing to reassure us that
anything will improve this time round we
would like to praise sir Roger Gail's
efforts in this regard as he hasn't been
afraid to stand up and be care counted
about
it I'm pleased to hear about your visit
to bro's College recently as well as the
impressive facilities you mention the
staff and students have also recently
developed a fantastic Forest school
which contributed to them being the
overall winner in the National
Conservation category at the km charity
School Green School prizes recently I've
visited a couple of times and see for
myself the enhancements they've made to
the surrounding environment and the
benefit it's had for several of the
students there who have re-engaged with
their education as a result of
it it's good to hear that the community
Champions conference at some augustin's
recently was well received many of us
across the chamber stood for election
because we were already actively
involved in our communities as part of
local community groups so there's quite
a blurry line between Community
activists and War counselors and as
Council Pew alluded to it can only be
helpful to the success of the program to
keep elected members both district and
town and Parish Council level fully
informed and involved as this program
and our other regeneration pro programs
progress we note the administration's
prompt response to the petition about
Jackie Bakers although there's much
still to be discussed and decided and
there was a good debate on this last
night's scrutiny panel meeting it's
encouraging for residents to see
concerns I've expressed taken seriously
and acted on
we also welcome the leader's commitment
to do something about about the
atrocious state of some of our public
toilet and I'm pleased to see progress
has been made again there was a lively
discussion on this last night and I'm
pleased to hear that the ad
Administration will be taking that on
board as I've stated previously we are
fully supportive of the plans to
increase our Council home stock
affordable homes for rent are the types
of accommodation we need across Planet
rather than the buring in number of four
four bedroom executive homes many of
which are being built and left empty
while we're pleased that these houses
are being purchased from the developer
it does beg a few questions about the
number of affordable homes built over
the last few years for which no
affordable housing delivery partner was
secured how many were there and how much
in commuted sums has been provided by
developers in lure of these homes
hopefully this will be clarified when
the long awaited section 106 reports for
the last four years are imminently
published and finally we were pleased to
welcome you in broadstairs to our
remembrance service on um at the
beginning of
November as well as giving us a chance
to remember the sacrifices made to
preserve our freedoms here it also gives
us a chance to reflect on conflicts
elsewhere in the world with no end in
sight and the people suffering because
of them while dis owing the earlier
unhelpful disruption it is true that
there are many residents across Planet
who have friends and family who have
been affected by the atrocities
committed in both Israel and Gaza
recently and we believe it's vital that
we do all we can to Lobby those national
leaders who aren't already to both call
for a ceasefire to stop the daily
senseless Slaughter and make whatever
diplomatic efforts are required to find
a long-term solution it's in that Spirit
of calling for peace where currently
there is none that we wish you all a
very happy
[Applause]
Christmas call upon the leader to
respond thank you chair and um I don't
think that the fact that we concentrate
in this chamber on matters that we can
affect directly should be taken to
should be interpreted to mean that we
disregard some of the horrible things
that are going on in the world um or
that any of us um would not wish to see
the fighting stop in um
Gaza uh and around it because I know
that it's a serious concern to many
members of this Council but I don't
think that we you can usefully use our
time here to talk about
it um yeah um I should have actually um
followed up on on the reference to ramg
you alluded to again I think of the
remarkable things about Ramsgate is that
they recently had crowd of over a
thousand people which is an
extraordinary crowd for a club in the
eighth tier um and and as and I think
that's one of the reasons they were able
to take so many people to Wimbledon
because they've built a big uh standing
in the community and a big following in
the community and um you know I'm I'm in
touch with them and and talk to them and
I certainly encourage them to carry on
because I think they're doing a great
job um I can assure you that um Chon
played a team in the eighth tier failed
to beat them um and as on sassy um you
know they're never short of
opportunities to embarrass their fans
um uh BR says College um yeah I was
really impressed with that and I think
that we hopefully will be able to move
forward with the um marget digital
development soon uh and work with them
even more
closely uh section 106 payments yeah um
I'm I'm pleased to hear that is coming
forward um something that we look
forward to and and be useful to
understand what has happened to some of
those section 106 properties I can't
tell you off the top of my head you
won't be
surprised um and I can't read the other
thing I've written down so I'm not going
to say it thank
you thank you I called upon councelor
Boro to comment on or ask questions in
relationship to the leader's report
please yeah thank you and uh yeah thank
you councilor Everett for uh giving me
advanced notice of the uh the motion uh
not the motion rather of your leaders
report um as most of what was um what I
was going to respond to has already been
addressed by colleagues and i' I've
already asked questions about the Winter
Gardens my my uh response is going to be
very short can I just say um because I
didn't mention it earlier regarding my
question to councelor Duckworth if I
could have a a written written answer on
that I think we we we come to that
conclusion any I'm hoping we did anyway
thank you very much yeah and um yeah
well well done Ramsgate and I'm a Chon
supporter as well
my father was born in sou7 and like the
leader I come from be we've got a few
things in common so I do support the
Reds still sometimes um and good job I
am a Chon supporter because I lost
emotion and Chon what was Jim Davis
calls him Chon nil doesn't he but anyway
there we go like the leader I
am I'm concerned after the announcement
of the the job losses in in in fisa um
which neverita will affect the people in
thanet in everyone's World um so uh you
know good on that one um I'm pleased
that you met uh councelor Everett I'm
pleased that you met with uh your
counterparts in do and Canterbury and I
eagerly uh wait for an update on the
situation regarding the fisa
thing our group is delighted uh that the
green light has been given for the bid
for3 3.2 million lottery funds uh for
the theater Royal and and I'm sure the
public feedback will be
positive so um as I said it's a just
just a short one cuz I think we've sort
of talked about everything that I wanted
to um regarding the the Migrant Center I
mean whatever our views on immigration
um I do have sympathy for the genuine
refugees and you know I'm I'm I'm
confident that the leader do doing the
right thing as far as that's concerned
so um I'm glad things were quite smooth
tonight and and things were you know
reasonably better than I thought they'd
be so um thank you very much for that
member's opposite it went quite well so
I'd like to wish uh everybody a Merry
Christmas I'd like to thank all the
officers for all the all the good work
they do um Colin and his team and and
everyone else and
um and the members as well so uh thank
you very much cheers thank you Council
War You' like to respond
leer well councelor I'm always um
convinced that whatever differences we
have we can always find things we have
in common and you've identified one that
we have in common so well done and um
thank you thank you for your comments
and uh uh I wish you a Merry
Christmas right thank you agenda item 10
scrutiny panel report of the chairman of
the overview and scrutiny panel I call
upon councelor fellows to present the
report uh thank you Mr chairman I'll
keep it brief because we've still got a
lot to get through my uh full report has
been circulated to all members as part
of this evening's agenda pack um but
I'll happy take any questions or
comments
sorry I do members have any
no
agenda item 11 adoption of the burington
neighborhood plan I call upon the leader
uh point of AUD
chair can I just point out that myself
and Council of rights are both burington
Parish counselors and uh although we
weren't part of the neighborhood plan
group it was a parish council initiative
it was a resident-led plan I just want
to point out to prevent any uh problems
later on in case there's any people
think there's a conflict I don't think
there's a conflict but I just wanted to
point that out
agree there's no
conflict okay
yes right adoption of burington
neighborhood plan I call upon the
leader I move that Council make the
biring of neighborhood
plan steady on now two members
agree right thank you agenda item 12
adoption of the Bro de and S Peter's
neighborhood plan a call upon councilor
ever sorry point of
order I know I know Council fellows has
just asked the question but there's a
number of broadstairs and St Peters Town
town councilors on uh the council assume
again there's uh no conflict of
interest thank
you right I call upon on Council ever
I'm reminded of the the late councelor
Peter Campbell who would would always
get up at Council meetings and ask
whether there was a conflict of interest
on the same same issue every single year
and every single year he got a response
that he wasn't but I understood why he
did it and I understand why members are
doing it um I move that Council make the
broad on St peters's neighborhood plan
review can I have a second
there do members agree
thank
you agenda item 13 local government
boundary commission for England and
review authentic District Council size I
call upon councelor
y thank you chair as part of the local
government boundary commission for
England's uh review into electoral
arrangements for an dist Council it
asked the council to create a submission
that reviews the number of councel as
this has and whether this number should
be increased or decreased and to what
extent the boundary electoral
Arrangements working party the baa the
be awp has undertaken that work on
behalf of the council the bewp have
considered a great deal of evidence
regarding the activities of the council
since the date of the last review in
2001 in order to be able to compare both
Council workloads the structure of the
council and the ways in which both the
council and members of the public uh
work and interact with each other the
bawp reacted uh reached the conclusion
based on the evidence that TDC TDC
should look to reduce the number coun
the amount of counselors that it has
from its current number 56 the evidence
to support this move is summarized in
the report but counselors and the public
can look at the agendas and minutes of
the bawp if they wish to look at the
evidence in more detail the link to the
relevant pages of the website are in the
report once the bewp decided that
Council should reduce its numbers it
then focused on on how many this is this
is then when the panel looked at the TDC
sien nearest neighbors these are not the
the council's physical neighbor
neighbors but the 15 council's closest
comparators over a variety of 40 metrics
using a wide range of so social economic
indicators the
lgbc ask asks us to have regard to the
elector ratio of our nearest neighbors
and not to be significantly above or
below them our elector ratio is the
number of electors in the in the
district divided by the number of
councilors you have the ba WP reviewed
evidence that showed the current TDC
elector ratio placed us significantly
below that of our peers
um the proposed number of councelors 42
will place Us in the very middle of our
sit for 15 nearest neighbors hence their
recommendation to council if the council
agrees the perspective number of 42
tonight then this number and the
supporting evidence contained within the
council submission will be submitted to
the lgbc prior to Christmas they'll then
confirm if any changes are needed or
whether the submission meets their
requirements and then they will make a
final decision on the number by
mid-march 2024 if agreed the new
Arrangements including revised Council
Awards will take effect on the next
Council election in May
2027 this report before members is a
culmination of many weeks of work by the
boundary and electoral Arrangements
working
party um and I would just like to thank
councilor Pacman officers the chair of
the uh um I'd like to thank councelor
Pacman who's the chair of the bwp the
officers and the panel for their
diligent work I propose that the council
accepts the recommendation the boundary
and electoral Arrangements working party
which is namely that proposed figure of
42 counselors to be the total number of
TDC counselors to be forwarded forwarded
forwarded to the local government
boundary commission for England the
lgbc thank
you thank you can I have a seconder
please Le you want to say something or
you second
it I'll second it and reserve the right
to speak than right anyone El want to
speak so you do you want to debate it in
the usual way
no let goby I do I do want to make one
comment and um I think the work of the
um the bewp has been really really good
but there just a point that Council y's
covered there that I do think does need
to be pointed out which is I'm not I was
originally a member of the bewp but I
couldn't make a number of the meetings
so Council Everett was um added at the
last council meeting but I did sub at
the recent meeting we went to the number
42 and we were presented as counselors
data and a graph which councelor Yates
referred to which in my view was
incorrect um and gave us the wrong
impression and I do think that needs to
be pointed out because the data showed
thanet population in 2030 as opposed to
our SI for Neighbors Mo current data or
historic data that might have been out
of date so we were being given
projections of where our per counselor
numbers were going to be but we were not
comparing apples with apples so I do
take the point that um we have
eventually got to the right figure but I
do I I'm disappointed that that is being
referred to again because at the meeting
we did discuss this and point out that
you're not actually comparing the
correct figures if you're comparing 10
years of growth in thanet and our
population changes you're comparing it
to other authorities and their current
or population from three or four years
ago I don't think that's a fair
comparison thank
you right thank you is anybody else want
to face councelor um
cup councelor cup coun cup councelor cup
councelor Cup
please oh sorry uh what you mean know
who I am you could see you oh sorry uh
thank you chair um I just wanted to
comment on on this uh in relation to is
it dodgy Mike
again can everyone hear me all right
loveely uh I just wanted to comment on
the work that's been undertaken on this
um I know how the working group has been
looking at all different kinds of
evidence and there's been a lot of
discussion around this um there's been a
lot of cross party work as well on this
which I think is really important um and
I just wanted to say as well that our
group will be supporting the
recommendation that's in this report
thank
you okay coun wing councelor
wing councelor wing sorry
thank you all right chair thank you
could I just ask uh do the numbers
reflect the deprivation that exists in
in thanet so I I know that many of us
work in wards where there's significant
deprivation which obviously generates an
extreme amount of work for for
counselors so does the 42 have a sort of
uh awaited towards uh areas of
deprivation cuz clearly 42 in an area
that's not that not as deprived as us
would would generate less Ward work than
an area that that has deprivation so
that that
clarification would be
great that's
Le yeah I mean you can't the fact of the
matter is that some WS are always going
to be busier than others and some areas
are always going to be busier than
others but you can't set I mean we have
some um serious deprivation in a number
of our Wards and we have some quite aent
Wards um and the reality in my
experience is that you might get a lot
of casew work in a deprived world you
might find that people in in areas of
deprivation are less able to navigate
the system and less likely to contact
their counselor and the areas in more
prosperous people in more prosperous
areas are better able to use the system
and and know where to go to get advice
so um I understand and we have asked
that question and that's been discussed
but I don't think it's a consideration
that we can really um take forward I I
wanted to disagree slightly with Michael
colleague councelor scobby um I I'm
really disappointed actually that we
couldn't persuade Mr Hughes to bring his
graph to the council meeting and and we
had great fun with his graph um but as
we've learned recently at the co inquiry
politicians don't understand graphs um
I'm I'm I'm I'm not accusing I'm not
accusing C scobby of not understanding
the graph but I do think he's wrong and
the reason I think he's wrong is because
um we can't know in 2030 how what number
of counselors um our statistical
neighbors will have because they may
have also had a review in the meantime
so even if we looked at their population
projections they wouldn't provide us
with any useful information and I think
it is unsatisfactory that ours is
effectively based on a projection of the
electorate which is based on a two
2014 uh population projection which is
incorporated into the local plan which
none of us believe is accurate but we
are where we are and it seems to me that
a reduction of a quarter in the size of
this council is appropriate and feels
right to most of us and I'm really
pleased that we could work cross party
on it um and I hope that continues thank
you
so son councelor
[Music]
Davis I couldn't thank you chair I'm
going to withdraw because councelor ever
actually um alluded my my point was that
this is purely numerical and I think
everyone in the chamber needs to
understand that um it's nothing about
deprivation we hearing that word a lot
this week even the football club seem to
think that we're some you know dystopian
nightmare well we're not um and you can
be extremely busy in non-deprived Wards
as well I just want that recorded thank
you council do you want yep um so just
to sum up um I would like to thank again
Council Pacman um members across the
part across the chamber for their work
in the ba WP um so I move the
recommendation um and I'll just repeat
it that proposed figure of 42 councilors
be the total number of TDC councils to
be forwarded to the local government
boundary commission for England the lgbc
thanks do members agree age age thank
you agenda item 14 midyear review 2023
stroke 24 treasur management and annual
investment strategy I called upon
councelor Yates thank you chair um this
report summarizes treasury management
activity and credential treasury
indicators for the first half of
2324 the following represents the key
reporting items to consider the 2324
mid-year capital expenditure and
long-term assets was £ 55.9
million uh against a full year budget of
60.7 million the council's gross debt
also called the barrowing position at
30th September 23 was £1 19.7 million
the council's underlying need toor
priority to finance this capital
expenditure also called the capital
financing requirements the CFR is
estimated to be 78.3 million at 31st of
March
24 um uh the council has held less gross
debt than at CPR and according
accordingly is comp uh comp complied
with the requirement not to exceed its
authorizing borrowing limit of 81
million as at 30th December 2023 the
council's investment balance was £ 55.4
million it is proposed that the 2324
treasury man man management strategy
statement to be amended as described in
section three of the reports this being
that both the operational boundary and
authorized limit for borrowing the 2324
tmss as referred to in section 3.1 of
the report be increased by2 million
pounds to reflect the increase in the
2324 HRA Capital program for the
acquisition and development of new
affordable housing units as referred to
in section 4.2 of the report and finally
the council makes comments on this
report and annexes as appropriate
approves the report and annexes
including the credential and treasury
indicators that are shown and the
proposed changes to the 2324 treasury
management strategy statement thank
you can I have a second
then do you wish to
debate
no do members agreed ag ag thank you
agenda item 15 key decision
definition I move that the
recommendation as set out in the re
report be adopted can I have a
seconder see
yes do you wish to
debate do members agree agree thank you
agenda item 16 review of the council's
policy framework I move that the
recommendation has set out in the report
be adopted can I have a second then
yeah do members wish to
debate no do members
agree thank
you agenda item 17 amendments Council
proceed the rules regarding frequency of
questions I move that the recommendation
has set out in the report be adopted can
I have a
second do you wish to debate it
councelor
Davis sorry straight in
or yeah all right I was I was showing
respect there I was going to defer for a
minute but hey
um very welcome uh however I think
there's a couple of uh dangers in this
in in this change um and and and and
obviously what does happen is that
things get backed up as we saw this
evening with substantially the same
issue particularly when the issue is
bigger in the community however uh this
alteration allows for um a decision to
be taken because because questions have
been properly submitted it doesn't mean
they've been heard it doesn't mean
they've been answered and it Le and and
there's a very real risk in this which
is that um questions could be hammered
in accepted never never never spoken in
the public domain and and no one can do
anything about it for 6 months so um
whilst I welcome anything that Smooths
the system I think that's uh probably a
risk too far and would like maybe all of
us to consider some form of amendment as
to how that how that's phrased because
uh for a question to be acceptable to
the uh to democratic services in this
Council but it may not be heard because
again thank you leader for what you did
earlier but for the second meeting many
of us didn't get to stay our about
questions we didn't get supplementary
questions and it'll all get washed away
in the in the outwash uh I think it's
quite important that there isn't a
mechanism that allows for manipulation
of how those questions will be raised
and I and I do believe that some form of
amendment's necessary to this thank
you thank you Council
Everett yeah I mean I was just going to
say that I've rarely um rarely can there
have been a a proposal come before the
council that was
more appropriately evidenced than by the
activity at the meeting because clearly
I mean and I absolutely understand that
the issue around warpole by tital pool
was of um extreme concern to the people
who asked the questions and I have
absolute respect for them wanting to
bring that matter before the council but
it isn't a sensible use of council time
to have eight questions which are
covering the same ground and therefore I
think this this tidying up of the
Constitution is is welcome I have to say
say that you know that's a very unusual
State of Affairs it's not something I
can never remember in a council meeting
before um but of course it could happen
again um I I hear what um councelor
Davis is saying I mean I think and a
member of my group asked um you know
what the process was around rejecting
questions and it's very important that
these decisions are made by officers
because it would be quite improper if
the leader was to decide which questions
should be asked and which questions
shouldn't be asked I mean that would not
be Democratic or appropriate and none of
us would want to go down that road um we
I do think we need to think about
constitutional matters and about the
procedures that we have in meetings
including around the time that we
allocate to questions um and there is a
um we are starting to do that with the
new monitoring officer um and we will be
bringing forward proposals in due course
and they will go through the usual
mechanisms because that's what the
Constitution says and everybody will
have an opportunity to talk so if
there's any problem that arises from
this I think we can address it quite
quickly and have those discussions I
think we should get on and pass this
motion and and if you would just indulge
me the one thing I forgot to say earlier
was um 42 is the meaning of life as
anybody of a certain age will know
that's why it's a good that's why it's a
good number for this Council thank
you Council
El yeah thank you chair as uh as the the
member was going to uh responding to all
the questions in relation to what to
wall Poole Bay one of the my view that I
put forward um was that when you get
something like that where
there's literally the same questions but
then there's uh differences with within
those questions from different people um
that why can't we have a compass site so
if you got seven questions have a
composite of those questions and each
bit and you can answer it in one go to
all of those questions and I just think
that that's uh A Better Way Forward
thank
you councel y councelor thank you chair
um I'm just responding to councelor
Davis as uh as my name's on top of this
report and I I do see there is a
potential as as a previous contract
manager and I'm down in the detail so
there is a I think you've raised a risk
which is multiple questions are
submitted by members of the public one
only one member is invited to speak and
they do not attend therefore the answer
is not um published so um
I I would quite like the advice of the
monitoring officer whether whether we
could include a phrase such as where
members where multiple questions are
submitted by members of the public and
only one member is invited to attend and
they do not attend then the question
shall be read out in the chamber um to
see if that would be a a suitable
addition that might solve this
issue
I don't AR here I'm just conferring with
Dem
services
for
for May I'm going to pass over to Mr
Hughes to provide a much more
comprehensive
response
I can see where you're coming from but I
don't think that you can change the
rules based upon tweaking
multiple uh recipients being able to put
a question when they're not present
because you then the principle of a
person not being here getting a written
response is actually a separate part of
the is a separate part of the question
scheme so you can't just tweak one
little bit of it when the when the
Constitution says there's a specific set
but I think as I say it's a fair point
to raise and I think if you want to
raise that as part of a future
constitutional review process we can
have a far more detailed debate and and
discussion about that at the
ciwp yeah so I think I'm I'm with
councilor Everett that we should pass it
but I think we do need to look at this
um because of that risk and um I do
acknowledge that point so I think
something we can look at uh to make
amendments but I think the
Constitutional review working party
might need to go back and potentially
look at that as well thanks point point
of order chair under 1.6.1 3 can Council
even amend this document without this
going back to standards and Constitution
review are we starting a Superfluous
discussion about potentially amending
something that we don't actually have
the power to amend because I saw about
six or seven different hands pop up
there we could be here a while if we
debate
something Council does have the ultimate
power to make those amendments although
obviously that's not the process that
this council's agreed But ultimately it
could make that
decision councilor F you want to get in
quick yeah thank you chair I do because
I know everyone wants to get home um and
maybe enjoy min's pie at home in the
comfort of their own home um I
understand the concerns that have been
raised and I think that it's it's right
to to be concerned and that and as has
been said by councelor Yates and by
councelor Davis the the devil is in the
detail and just whilst we've uh had this
discussion I've been checking over the
agenda item and and of course uh you
know
to understand what substantially may be
the same as a similar question that was
asked three months ago all the way up to
six months ago I think we run the risk
of particularly as fast as fastpaced and
moving as local government is as we all
know in that a question could be put to
say this Council um something to do with
the local plan or development or housing
developments as has already been done at
this very meeting and then similar
questions to that purely on the local
plan could then be rejected for the next
6 months when something May May
potentially move on within that time so
I understand and I think that's where
the wording is of substantially the same
is is is a bit too vague because and I
appreciate that officers will have to
make the call on that but 6 months to me
sounds like quite a long time
considering that for full Council we
normally have a full Council every other
month so I would suggest that we either
change it to a three-month period or
that we have a trial period where we
let's see how they go see how this goes
if we're allowed to do that um and if re
revert back to the sister before but I
appreciate the reasoning why we've had
to bring this in because it's been shown
tonight councelor
Wing councelor critton was before
me coun thank thank you I I was um I
actually just wanted to ask um very
similar to the point of order from my
colleague here um whether or not we can
given that we are already coming up for
gone C depart 9 UM and the debate that
we've got going on can we refer this
back to the Constitutional review
working party as a decision of tonight
because there obviously our concerns um
and can we make that as a
decision could I suggest that that's a
very wise suggestion I mean ingred is
right the council has a final say but it
can't be wise to debate this kind of
detail that's what standard Committee in
constitutional working is for so if if
councilors aren't happy I would agree
with the suggestion to refer it
back you'd have to agree to do that but
that's what I
suggest do do we agree on that
then there's no motion yet someone's
got do you want a proposal on the second
yeah so hang
on right so I've been told if I withdraw
the motion then somebody else can put a
motion forward and debate it
again
I have done it so would have order does
that need my consent if I seconded
it okay well just to save time I I'll
consent
yeah does that mean what I suggested now
I can make us an alternative motion that
we refer this back to the
crwp um and to go through the process so
that they can review all of the comments
that have been made
tonight
fine second you second the motion to the
members of oh do you want to debate
youate you you want to debate it again
then no I don't I want to make sure my
comment goes back to the review party
but I do support the the the motion but
what I'd like to say is how actually big
is the problem I mean I'm just in my
second term and I can't remember
multiple questions coming up until this
term one was the M the manston motion
the manston questions that were the last
meeting that came from members and then
today we've had the w pole Bay and I
actually think I fully support what
councilor alurn says we need to remember
that even as members being able to
submit a question and ask that question
in a council meeting is extremely
important particularly if you're not
part of the the the the uh the count the
ruling group or the opposing group it's
even more important that we give
residents a platform form to ask their
questions so to reject questions because
they might be similar I think is simply
wrong and I would support that all those
questions are read out and then one
Global answer is is given because it's
not much fun listening to repeated
answers so I just wanted to make sure
that that those comments are heard and I
fully support the motion the new
motion counc M
you yeah I'll be I'll be very very brief
um I I do bear a little bit
responsibility for that this evening and
I I apologize but it's actually good to
see because that's what democracy is
about is is local residents feeling they
can come into the council and ask
questions and I'm uh very concerned that
we shouldn't um undermine that in any
way especially given the the late hour
to debate it now um I was contacted by a
number of local residents concerned
about war Poole Bay uh and the Damage
that has been caused there and I think
as a way to end the evening uh we were a
victim of our own success as a council
because the technical services team have
done such a brilliant job of putting the
the title PA right uh that several of
the people who are questioning didn't
feel the need to come in and ask their
questions because the problem had
already been solved so for that I'm uh
they and I are very grateful thank you
right counc scobby I'm not 100% sure
where we are in terms of decision-
making I believe that I'm seconding
councelor crittendon's
proposal you second okay well I would
like to speak on that then um there
there's a couple of things here we are
we are un unfortunately merging two
things there is a proposal to make a
small amendment to make sure that time
is prioritized because you've got to
remember questions from members of the
public and questions from counselors are
time limited so if you have multiple
through it actually stops other issues
from being talked about now there are
other points being raised by people
about changes in the Constitution and at
the Constitutional review working part
where we disc discuss this as Council
rever alluded to there are other
elements of the Constitution that need
to be looked at including the petition
scheme and other elements of debate here
I think we're clouding this slightly I
think because members are concerned they
want to add in things we have somehow
got to a point where a small amendment
to the Constitution is now going back
through a process to probably come back
and um the situation that Council spoke
about where there is going to be a wider
review is now going to get stuck into
this um it's it's disappointing that
we've done this and the motions have
already been passed I will be supporting
it and hopefully we can when this comes
next time not conflate two issues here
and actually look at the detail of it
not our other concerns about the
Constitution thank you
chair councilor Davis thank you chair um
councilor scob is just used the phrase
that he'll support the the secondary
motion which which is excellent news all
i' wanted to point out was um small
Amendment massive potential implications
so Council vad
please thank you chair um happy to
support
the happy to support the amended motion
um just in terms of potential
recommendations to take forward might I
suggest that a quite simple alteration
might solve a lot of these issues in
that if we simply change it to is
substantially the same as a question
which has been answered at a meeting of
the council in the past six months that
then stops questions disappearing if
people aren't present so if that's to be
considered in the future I would like to
put that forward as a suggestion thank
you yeah Council ever I'm just just to
make the comment to members that um the
Constitution review working panel um is
an open meeting um to which people can
come along and speak under 20.1 and I
think that the reason we're having this
discussion in tonight um is that people
haven't considered the issues um early
enough to have an input into that
process um because really by the time
they get here and this is the
decision-making body but by the time
they get here we should have clarified
our views um and if there's a legitimate
dispute then fine they can be voted for
on the floor of the council but I think
that What's Happening Here is because
people haven't considered the papers as
they've gone through Constitution review
working panel so I would encourage
people um even if they can't come along
the meeting um to read the papers for
those meetings and participate if
they're able and then we can have those
discussions in a forum which is probably
more appropriate thank Council Green
Point of V chair can I move that the
motion be put
second
right so can we put it back to the
Constitution R party then
please
so uh it's normal sometimes have a
Chairman's drink unfortunately we
thought that uh officers thought that it
would take too long tonight and wouldn't
be having any time and secondly I
couldn't find any socialist
champagne and I wish you all Merry
Christmas
for